but all nba first team you got anthony
davis my favorite player
along with lebron james and so
two first-team all-nba guys i'm
wondering
mike if you see any pressure if lakers
fans
like our friend of the show o'shea
jackson jr if they feel any pressure
because it's very rare to have first two
first-team all-nba guys the last time it
happened in the nba was 2006 2007. amari
sotomayor steve nash
they didn't win the championship back in
the day you had moses malone and doc
obviously they won shaq and kobe did it
several times think three times
they won a championship but when you
when you're in that position
you're almost it's almost like you got
to win
if you didn't win what's wrong with you
do you think
they feel any pressure does frank vogel
feel any pressure
well well of course i mean the lakers
always feel that way whether or not
anthony davis and lebron james were on
you know the first team second team
third team what regardless i mean that
was the expectation
when they got anthony davis and now you
compound it with the fact that
and that's that's an interesting lesson
i'm not i don't wanna
this isn't about the for me your
pressure question isn't necessarily
about the
distinction and the honor of having two
all-nba players first-team all-nba
players which is fantastic
the pressure question is just about not
just the lakers as a franchise and their
lofty standards
not just having both lebron and anthony
davis
the pressure question is really about
this year and you know
uh the tragic passing of kobe bryant
and the the legacy and the weight that
this franchise is carrying in order to
win
in his honor um it's a friend it's a fan
base that's
you know they're spoiled as you know you
know
and so they're not they're not they're
not starved
for a championship but they but they're
used to eating regularly so to speak and
so
they're waiting for a championship and
they feel like this year not
especially now that they've got the
clippers it reminded me a lot of 0-4
michael when the red sox it was better
to come back against the yankees and win
the world series
they feel so good about the clippers you
know um
you know choking away the game the
series against the nuggets so yeah the
clippers are out so now you're facing a
team
that wasn't supposed to be there and so
it'll be interesting to see how that
pressure manifests itself with the
nuggets playing so loose and the lakers
knowing that hey this is our year we're
doing this for kobe having said all of
that michael
there is no pressure at least in my mind
on lebron james because win or lose
if i could pivot back to the first steam
all nba selection
yeah go ahead six tell that times he's
been an
all-nba player most ever it's like wait
another accolade and so we were talking
earlier michael what
it's incredible more than anybody we
were talking earlier oh so let me finish
my point
and now pivot to something else i don't
know that
a championship at least for me it
doesn't affect lebron's legacy either
way i don't
i don't look at it as oh yeah exactly
like if he wins it
he's one of the greatest ever if he
loses it he's still one of the greatest
ever
you